dear God of anime I know it's been a
while since we last talked but how're
you doing I've been doing pretty good
and I can see that you've been pretty
busy yourself with all the new anime
you've been pumping out this season's
pin alright so far I mean mob psycho
hundred is pretty good and 91 days is
decent but hey great going on that
Reiser oh man everyone is eating that
[ __ ] up like crack but uh do we really
need another source online movie nope
you know what I trust that you know what
you do so let's not go there
anyway I don't want to take up too much
of your time as I know you're a busy guy
and also all I really wanted to ask
exact you make another season of one
punch man the first season was pretty
dope and you know was pretty popular too
so I'm sure the whole world wouldn't
mind seeing a bit more of it cool
alright that's pretty much all of it
thanks bye though if you did have a bit
more time on your hands there were a few
more things I wanted to see if we're
still talking sequels I don't know how
many more years you're gonna make me
wait for another season of Barca no I
mean you gave one to Dora so don't tell
me it's not possible alright it's not
like I've spent last nine years brain
for you to make this happen or anything
also while you're at it how about
another season of splicing wolf look you
gave us a legitimately interesting show
about economics then took that away from
us so now what the hell are we supposed
to watch do you even know how boring
economics really is when it's not a
naked wolf lady that comes with it it's
really [ __ ] boring all right I mean
compared to that the finance Channel is
just like well it just looks like a
bunch of pompous [ __ ] arguing about
numbers really and don't even get me
started on how you left a hairy he
franchise look I don't care how many
dudes aya hirano is banked and I'm sure
nobody else does still care except for
possibly the bass guitarist but you
can't make one of the greatest franchise
films of all time and then just leave it
there
look I'd even say people doing the
[ __ ] Harry Harry UK dies in public
again if I could see more Harry he
alright what happens to kyon when he
opens the door are they actually having
hotpot is how are he being an arrogant
boy
[ __ ] again is the world on fire is
there a massive orgy going on I need to
know and I know there's more sequels I
need but on this topic madhouse yes I'm
talking to you studio
I [ __ ] hate making sequels madhouse
how about you stop making half these to
the shows and just ending it at a single
season yeah you may think people will
forget the amount of times you've dang
good plot points for another season in
front of us in shows like High School of
the Dead no game no life over Lord Batum
and one punch man but we don't it's
engrained in our minds eternally and
we're still waiting look I get it
working on red line for seven goddamn
years has given you some commitment
issues but it's been what seven years
since that was released now it's time to
get back in the game man settle on a
show or two to stick with til the end
and you might even make a fair buck from
it look what Shafter done with Monica
tree and a one I've done with okay bad
example just don't take sequel advice
from bones okay that's all I really ask
bones I love you but darker than black
season 2 and a ruckus 7ar have just kind
of scarred me for life and also don't
listen to Gainax of our endings either
[ __ ] fan against [ __ ] actually
madhouse you know what screw the sequel
thing all you really need to do to make
me happy is the complete anime
adaptation of 20th century boys like you
did with monster now I've been fighting
over the naysayers who've been telling
me that you'll never do it in this day
and age but I have faith maybe you'd be
more interested in it if Cuomo de Toro
actually got the live action monster
approved maybe and maybe you'd give me
the shown an adaptation of siren like I
always wanted come on you know it'd be
better than 90% of the other shonas
coming out right now
I mean you gave the carmaker [ __ ]
kill a bloody shot so it can't be that
unlikely right but if I can't have that
how badges are shown in with a
tournament no I don't mean like the
Battle Royale free throws we see
everywhere nowadays or that one in one
piece just a pure one-on-one battle mano
y mano like we used to see literally
everywhere in the old days not that I
don't love shokugeki but there is a
difference between seeing fists flying
on each other and watching people having
multiple orgasms at the sight of some
cheese on toast you know also miss the
god of anime can you please say
something to the devil of anime because
I am tired of him pissing all over the
berserk franchise now I don't know who
sold their soul to the devil
get more berserk mate but now we know
that the [ __ ] catch was it would make
any berserk fan want to burn our
eyeballs that would hot iron now I'm not
sure if he cursed this franchise or
something but it would be nice if it
finally got the adaptation it deserved
you know a full-length series that is
not a PowerPoint presentation slide show
without the same so I'm not an amateur
CG animation that would make anyone who
watches it want to castrate themselves
with a pair of pliers also tell me your
I said hi
tell him it's no rush but I do hope I
can see the end of berserk in my
lifetime no pressure also while you're
there tell her I'm looking forward to
seeing the end of one piece in my next
life when I like to note though I see
that you've watched my 5 concepts I'd
like to see an anime video since you're
actually making an eSports anime thanks
for that I genuinely didn't know about
it until half the viewers of that video
told me about it wait what do you mean
this isn't an anime what this is being
made in China you say so that means it's
technically a Chinese cartoon oh ok well
this is awkward
movie-going well I one day be able to
hear Steve blooms sexy voice in another
anime heck I'd even say Crispin Freeman
again I know that we're trying to
broaden our voice acting pool above
these two when the lead Johnny Yong
Bosch and Lisa Christian we had 10 years
ago but I've yet to encounter another
voice I could caress my eardrums and
such sensual pleasures their voices did
back in the day
no homo ah Who am I kidding complete
[ __ ] homo and how about a horror
anime that is actually scary
don't get cocky cuz a bunch of people
thought my lollies can't be this crazy
and yet another gorefest was scary I am
talking about a proper suspenseful show
that is entirely dedicated to horror not
this hey I'm gonna label this as horror
but it's really a shown in action show
of what's the blood we all know your
people can do live action horror
masterfully so why is it so difficult to
translate this into an anime show
monster and perfectly are the closest
you've definitely come but I'm sure you
can come up with an amazing horror that
isn't just psychological speaking of
things that need to be made hats off to
you for finally getting keys a mano out
and everything but is they've an Gillian
4.0 gonna follow in its footsteps
anytime soon I mean have you given
Hideaki anno crippling depression again
or is the wait for foreplay no the
actual ending to the rebuild of
evangelion which would only be slightly
more satisfying than ya chewin of
Evangelion but aside from all this do
you know what I miss
original stories and complete endings
not that I have a problem with light
novel adaptations but there is just a
tiny bit too much going on now isn't
there maybe you could throw some
original IPRA once in a while so we know
that we're gonna get a complete story
from the start but I know studios don't
like taking risks on new things so how
about this how about we just get
adaptations of source material that is
already complete I know that's pretty
mind-blowing there have been way too
many 12-episode anime recently that only
exists as a glorified advertisement to
their source material what happened to
the good old days when having at least a
24 episode series was the norm and
everything above that was the exception
endings that would tie up everything it
needed in a nice little package instead
of the usual legions of fans ask me how
much source material there is available
or an ending consisting of an anime
studio going is is this gonna make money
I mean will make another season of it if
it
makes money maybe probably not no more
of that okay and erased doesn't [ __ ]
count anyway that that sums everything
up I know you're a busy geezer but I do
hope see some of these things one day
love and kisses sender a fuck-boy 95 aka
gig ugh oh and PS I'm still waiting for
you to make why freeze real yeah hey
guys hope you enjoyed the video thank
you very much this month - Gabe roun
Thomas B Vinson Moony miraDry
and everyone not supporting me on
patreon for making this possible now if
you think I missed something that you'd
want to see from anime please leave a
comment telling me or do your own open
letter since I'm sure I forgot something
that we all want right anyway that's it
for me no updates for me this time I've
been gay and I'll see you all next time